alors que dix huit antennes des assedic
sont occupés par des chômeurs
gouvernement et syndicats posent la
question qui agit en sous main et que
les l'ampleur réelle du mouvement
tempête sur la france des banques aux
reproches de 100 kilomètres/heure
aujourd'hui mais le mauvais temps se
déplace vers l'est les îles bretonnes de
nouveaux reliée au continent voitures
brûlées violence comme en europe prendre
en mains les plus jeunes délinquants
emprisonné c'est le travail des unités
d'éducation renforcés reportage dans ce
journal
il ya 11 ans disparaissait le chanteur
daniel balavoine sa fondation pour
l'afrique veut éviter toute corruption
l'argent n'est donc distribué que pour
des projets limités bien concret enquête
dans ce journal
titanic la plus grande catastrophe de
l'histoire maritime porter à l'écran la
plus grosse production
l'histoire du cinéma américain
l'occasion également d'entendre le
témoignage du dernier survivant france à
ne pas manquer madame monsieur bonsoir
le mouvement de révolte de certains
chômeurs aura dépassé la semaine des
fêtes de noël et du jour de l'an et se
présente comme le premier problème
politique sérieux du gouvernement jospin
ce soir 18 locaux des assedic eux sont
occupés dans toute la france dont 8 pour
le seul département des bouches du rhône
ce mouvement provoque des réactions sur
le plan politique et syndical sur sa
réelle importance et à propos d'une
manipulation éventuelle de la détresse
comme l'a souligné aujourd'hui nicole
notât la cfdt nous y reviendrons dans un
instant mais d'abord sur le terrain les
occupations n'ont donc pas cessé alors
qu'après la fermeture pendant les fêtes
et bien les assedic rouvraient leurs
portes aujourd'hui reportage à lille et
arras admis patrick jour sans une
banderole quelques slogans
le dispositif est maintenant bien régler
chaque matin quelques chômeurs viennent
occuper les hassidiques de lille
une occupation pacifique pour ne pas
gêner le traitement des dossiers
les allocataires font la queue comme
tout les jours la plupart semblent
indifférents et pas toujours solidaire
les gens ont besoin d'argent pour vivre
sa peine mais ils ont surtout besoin de
travailler pour gagner de l'argent
je pense pas que donner les allocations
pour des gens qui ne travaillent pas une
bonne chose
donc c'est pas de l'argent du conseil de
l'emploi à quelques kilomètres de là
arras c'est à la direction que l'on
reçoit des chômeurs l'antenne principale
des assedic est fermé pour cause
d'occupation accueil de fortune on est
loin des 17 bureaux habituellement
proposée ici c'est beaucoup moins 12
mois on m'a confortée - victime
donc à chaque fois on n'a pas les
documents près de toi donc on s'est
toujours dit ali est venu sans doute
j'ai fait une demande de révision
ça traîne ça traîne à cause de ça j'ai
toujours pas de réponse et je suis
embêté pourquoi vous êtes endettés pour
l'événement pour pouvoir essayer de
continuer à travailler à penser à
assumer au dossier donc un petit peu
dans des conditions exceptionnelles
mille chômeurs en attente d'inscription
80 mille autres à indemniser impossible
de tout traiter le personnel est débordé
ici on craint les retards de paiement
nous sommes en pleine période de
paiement mensuel à 65000 paiement qui
doit se mettre en route
donc le fait de ne pas disposer de
l'outil de travail qui est le nôtre où
préoccupe énormément
la situation pourrait s'aggraver en fin
d'après-midi les chômeurs qui occupent
les assedic ont manifesté une nouvelle
fois dans les rues d'arras
ils étaient environ 200 bien décidés à
poursuivre leur action
une évacuation aujourd'hui les locaux
assedic de limoux dans l'aude les crs
sont intervenus pour évacuer une
vingtaine de personnes qui se trouvaient
dans les locaux sans violence véritable
quelques petits mots donc à l'arrivée
des crs la colère des chômeurs qui
occupent les assedic est montée d'un
cran aujourd'hui dans la mesure où dix
estiment qu'on a tenté de les berner
martine aubry ministre de l'emploi et de
la solidarité ayant annoncé
l'attribution d'une somme de 500
millions de francs par l'état alors
qu'en fait cette somme était déjà dû par
les pouvoirs publics au titre de l'année
passée par ailleurs politiques et
syndicalistes s'interrogent sur les
dessous de ce mouvement gouvernement
dominique voynet pour à la cfdt nicole
notât mais l'once une manipulation et
marc blondel de force ouvrière va plus
loin en parlant d'une action dirigée par
le parti communiste est récupéré par la
cgt laurent bailly jean-paul chaud c'est
à l'antenne assedic d'asnières la vie
continue bien qu'une trentaine de
chômeurs occupent les locaux
depuis ce matin bombay l'urgence c'est
maintenant c'est cet hiver assemblée
générale et pétitions diverses
ici les occupants appartiennent à
plusieurs comités de chômeurs des
organisations dont nicole notât conteste
la légitimité surtout affirme-t-elle
j'ai le sentiment qu'il y à de la
manipulation de la détresse
derrière tout ça du coup soutien
inattendu de marc blondel
comme elle ils reprochent au
gouvernement de traiter directement avec
les associations en écartant et fo et la
cfdt il a plu aussi la cgt de noyauter
avec le pc les comités de chômeurs la
cgt qui chercherait ainsi à s'imposer
comme la centrale syndicale des chômeurs
elle a pas réussi très exactement ce
qu'elle voulait alors par le canal du
parti lfl amiraux place les autres
structures et matt noël les récupère
dans la bagarre mais si j'étais s'honore
d'être à l'initiative du mouvement
revendicatif des chômeurs parce que ce
qui compte c'est l'urgence des
revendications celles que portent les
chômeurs et que soutient l'ensemble de
l'opinion publique
eh bien oui nous pensons que nous jouons
notre rôle de syndicat sur le terrain
les associations récusent toute
récupération
la cgt est présente avec nous parmi nous
que je sache c'est personnes dirigent
nous décidons collectivement dans cette
affaire de manipulation c'est purement
et simplement pour discréditer le
mouvement dont on est récupéré par
personne nous on se bat en une
association de chômeurs on se bat pour
les chômeurs on les aide dans les
démarches et a rien de politique quoi en
tout cas ces militants ne désarment pas
ils veulent faire entrer dans le
mouvement
davantage de demandeurs d'emploi pour
accentuer la pression encore beaucoup de
vent aujourd'hui sur la france une
tempête qui se déplace de l'ouest vers
l'est malgré des vents soufflent encore
à près de 100 kilomètres heure les îles
bretonnes comme wes ans ont pu renouer
le contact avec le continent et évacuer
les touristes art de boutet luc bachofen
donc bien dans un instant avec le
commentaire de ce reportage sur la
bretagne mais il ya également du mauvais
temps dont qui part vers l'est et la
tempête se déplace donc d'ouest en est
et ne touche pas seulement la france
l'allemagne la belgique et l'angleterre
sont également concernés olivier gasnier
personne ne se plaint la mairie bichonne
ses visiteurs est en panne à tour de
bras des certificats d'indisponibilité
des papiers très officielle pour
justifier aux employeurs cette absence
prolongée
donc on a un tout petit problème cette
fois ci c'était le son du reportage
précédent il ya des soirs comme ça où
les choses ne vont pas très bien avant
de revenir donc sur ces deux reportages
c'est promis et chaque fois en pareille
circonstance se pose le problème du
paiement des dégâts par les assurances
ces dernières tempêtes n'échappe pas à
la règle jacques devaux il ya brillé le
camélia c'est la ronde des artisans
celle ébauchée cette fois c'est le
peintre vendredi la tempête a emporté
une partie du toit et l'heure est
désormais au bilan il ya quand même par
kevin ici l'agent d'assurance et
spontanément déplacer mais avec des
assurances la méfiance est toujours de
mise
tous les hommages qu'on a on est
vraiment inquiet quand même pouvoir
donner il reste que on va voir à donner
côté assureurs on n'a pas chômé
la journée était placée sous le signe
des déclarations de sinistres
une centaine de déclaration pour
l'habitation plus ces déclarations sont
faites par courrier par téléphone
la toiture qui s'envole et l'eau qui
s'infiltre travers ça c'est de la
tempête il faut déclarer dans les cinq
jours et l'assureur envoie un expert
pour chiffrer les dommages
par contre si la rivière a débordé s'il
ya des coups de boule à ce sont des
inondations qui relève des catastrophes
naturelles et pour être indemnisé il
faut qu'il y ait un arrêté
interministériel qui paraissent au
journal officiel
s'il n'y a pas eu d'inondation la mairie
de redon a malgré tout décidé de monter
un dossier de classement en catastrophe
naturelle
cela peut toujours être utile d'y
tourner autour maintenant dans l'ordre
donc sur les péripéties autour de l'île
d'ouessant qui est de nouveau relier au
continent c'était à partir de cet après
midi arnaud boutet lui bachofen lorsque
la mer est impraticable seul reste la
voie des airs première liaison ce matin
entre brest et ouessant depuis samedi
lille était coupé du continent livré aux
bourrasques elle des vacances prolongées
pour près de 400 sources
on va tous les matins pour le bulletin
météo de 11 heures et après ça comment
les fixes et les puits a décrit vendredi
sur le manque de bateaux en face après
midi à se balader à se réfugier dans les
cas c'est un fonction les averses les
produits commençaient à manquer la
boucherie a dû fermer personne ne se
plaint la mairie bichonne ses visiteurs
est en panne à tour de bras des
certificats d'indisponibilité des
papiers très officielle pour justifier
aux employeurs cette absence prolongée
à 14 heures la nouvelle est officielle
le bateau se dirige vers lille
tout le monde peut enfin parti certes le
vent fatigue mais l' isolement on y
prend quoi ces quatre jours ont
rapproché touristes et ouais santin dans
l'alcool et la bonne humeur à tel point
que certains d'y faire leur départ ont
fait plus connaissance avec les gens qui
sans bretelles
et on devient plus copain avec les
patrons parce qu'elle lui promiscuité
involontaire plus que la blonde et
l'obligation de partir il fallait un
coeur bien accroché cette affaire
au large les creux mesure dit m et le
vent souffle à plus de 120 km heure sur
lequel se mélangent sourires et regards
d'un pied et chacun se rassure commune
vapeur suis pas inquiet ça me contente
égal si le monde doit arriver arrivera
aujourd'hui ça n'a aucune importance
chaque année où il s'en est traversée
par ce type de conditions durant
plusieurs jours lille est totalement
coupé du continent mais ici on a
l'habitude tout le monde sait qu après
la tempête le calme revient le mauvais
temps se déplace donc d'ouest en est et
ne touche pas seulement la france
l'allemagne la belgique et l'angleterre
sont également concernés olivier gasse
pas de classes à redon un arbre est
tombé sur le toit de l'école les
professeurs n'étaient cependant pas venu
pour rien ce matin ils ont donné
l'exemple
un exemple guère suivis par les élèves
trop content de prolonger leurs vacances
oui c'est moi aujourd'hui ni demain ni
après-demain chercher même si les vents
violents continuent encore à souffler
sur la bretagne et même si plus d'un
millier de foyers vendéens reste ce soir
sans électricité
l'ouest de la france respire car le gros
de la tempête est bel et bien passé
venus de l'atlantique les intempéries se
sont déplacés vers l'est vers
l'allemagne l'allemagne du nord
notamment qui ce matin s'est réveillés
les pieds dans l'eau comme ici à
hambourg où la ville a partiellement été
inondées mais la zone de l'europe
incontestablement la plus touchée par
cette tempête
reste le sud ouest de l'angleterre au
pays de galles un homme est mort
dimanche
écrasé par un arbre dans son véhicule et
plusieurs personnes sont encore
hospitalisées
déchirée par les vagues et balayé par
des vents allant jusqu'à 160 kilomètres
heure une partie de la côte anglaise
reste ce soir privés d'électricité privé
aussi de transport en commun
isolé dans la tourmente comment endiguer
la violence dans les banlieues en ce
début d'année le gouvernement hésite
entre répression et prévention comment
conjuguer les deux selon un sondage ifop
publié par le journal libération
aujourd'hui 66 % des français estiment
qu'il faut renforcer la présence
policière dans les quartiers difficiles
et 82% pensent que la violence a atteint
un niveau inquiétant jamais connu
auparavant
sur le terrain la nuit dernière une
nouvelle série d' incendies d'une
vingtaine de véhicules
c'était à saint-etienne reportage didier
guyot olivier jacquin un réveil brutal
pour certains habitants du quartier de
montchauvet à saint-etienne 7000 en
voiture sont partis en fumée une
vingtaine au total brûlés par des
cocktails molotov entre 21h et 23h les
policiers ont bien tenté d'intervenir
mais en vain difficile d'arrêter des
petits groupes de jeunes qui acquièrent
ou en voiture s'évanouissent qu'aussitôt
dans la nuit une fois leur forfait
accompli le mal était déjà fait sa
course en voiture est complètement
la flamme le quartier pourtant paisible
bas jusqu'à ses ouïes on a retrouvé ses
repères patrick bauchau fait part c'est
calme subitement et rauscher montchauvet
le taux de rmi le plus élevé de la
région rhône alpes avec deux tiers
d'immigrés les chômeurs et les laissés
pour compte sont ici très nombreux et
pourtant des millions de francs est
investie des projets existent des
habitants se battent pour leur quartier
mais hier soir ce sont des têtes brûlées
comme on les appelle ici qu'ils ont
voulu faire parler d'eux ils ont entre
12 et 17 ans estime à l'abandon et
rejette la société sont des actes
entièrement gratuit un groupe de près
adolescents qui se livrent à des actes
de jeu malheureusement de jeu de jeu qui
propose effectivement des graves
difficultés sociales chez nous on est
chanceux dans leur jeu
complètement dehors de ces par bravade
pour imiter tout simplement ce qui s'est
passé à strasbourg que des adolescents
ont brûlé hier soir des voitures
un jeu qui attriste et qui exaspère les
habitants de quartiers et le monstre
guerre le procureur de strasbourg qui
avait sonné vos critiques et les mesures
policières prises pendant le réveillon
par le préfet du bas rhin a été reçu ce
soir au ministère de la justice réunion
discrète n'est toujours pas terminé à
strasbourg justement après des dizaines
de voitures incendiées à l'occasion des
fêtes de fin d'année jugement très
sévère aujourd'hui pour quatre jeunes
gens âgés de 18 à 24 ans 9 mois à 2 ans
de prison ferme christine bosses pas tu
échoues maker rarement une audience du
tribunal correctionnel de strasbourg
avait suscité autant d'intérêt
médiatique à l'ordre du jour quatre
jeunes jugés en comparution immédiate
pour destruction de véhicule par
incendie volontaire car après les
flambées de violence qui ont occasionné
85 incendies de voitures dans les
quartiers périphériques de strasbourg
depuis le début de l'année les
interpellations se succèdent à ce jour
31 jeunes ont été interpellés dont une
quinzaine de mineurs l'un d'entre eux
âgé de 17 ans est soupçonné d'avoir mis
le feu à une douzaine de véhicules
depuis le 25 décembre
parmi les quatre jeunes jugés
aujourd'hui par le tribunal
correctionnel aucun délinquant notoire
des jeunes sans repères à peine
conscient de la gravité de leurs actes
les peines prononcées de 9 mois à 2 ans
de prison ferme monde au delà des
réquisitions du procureur je le
craignais ça se vérifier que ce soit
jugement exemplaire s qui servira on
sait rien ça signifie qu'il valait mieux
ne pas être jugé aujourd'hui j'y ai
réfléchi mais comme je ne pense pas que
nos événements vont cesser du jour au
lendemain je suis pas sûr qu'on a une
composition plus clémente un autre jour
donc je fais confiance aux juges puis
j'ai pris le risque avec ces peines
d'une sévérité exemplaire le tribunal
correctionnel de strasbourg a sans aucun
doute voulu marquer les esprits mais
lesquels ceux de ces jeunes de leurs
victimes ou de l'opinion publique
comment faire pour allier répression et
prévention c'est la grande question donc
posée au gouvernement et aux hommes
politiques des tentatives ont eu lieu
comme celle des unités d'éducation
renforcés initié par le précédent
ministre de la justice jacques toubon
à partir du moment où les délinquants
sans être vraiment plus nombreux sont
plus jeunes et beaucoup plus dangereux
il s'agit de leur proposer pour sortir
de un temps de la prison une forme
d'éducation très surveillée pour leur
réapprendre tout simplement à vivre en
société aime bien sûr j'y passe
castelletta année dans ici tu t'en sers
pour bloquer sur le sur le bras et tu
fais le biais d'accords
la leçon est toute simple mais elle fait
partie du contrat que vincent a passé
avec la justice il était en prison
lorsqu'un juge lui a proposé cette
alternative dix semaines d'encadrement
renforcée pour reprendre avec des
éducateurs son histoire à 0 10 semaines
sans visite s'en sortir seul sans
famille juste se servir du quotidien
pour retrouver des repères
tous les matins on travaille comme ça
quoi
à quoi ça sert de travailler c'est la
question
les dix semaines serviront à cela
trouver des réponses pour éviter les
passages à l'acte qui mène en prison
et lorsque vincent évoque justement la
prison il parle de cas sur lui des
traces et trop longtemps mais il fallait
que j'y aille pour port pour me remettre
dans le bon chemin
c'est l'écueil aille parce que j'avais
pas compris à ccc comme un savoir faire
qu'on veut plus faire ce qu'on veut plus
l'utiliser parce que ça fait du mal à
tout le monde à tous les proches aux
victimes en tout soi-même la prison et
dans chacune de leur histoire parce
qu'ils y sont allés parce qu'un seul
nouveau dérapage suffirait à les y
conduire
ils ont entre 13 et 17 ans et sont
multirécidivistes vols violences
agressions
c'est sur ce passé là qu'ils vont devoir
s'attarder et travailler en retrouvant
des gestes ordinaires et les mots pour
le dire et surtout en apprenant la loi
mais finalement c'est pas l'activité qui
est très très importante c'est plutôt le
fait que pendant ces 10 semaines niveau
il faut être en contact avec un adulte
et avec un adulte qui les considèrent
j'ai déjà content là j'ai la prétention
de dire pour la première fois qu'ils les
considèrent comme quelqu'un de
responsable
on leur apprend ainsi que dans une
société on peut pas tout accepter il ya
des règles il faut les respecter quoi
après ce groupe après vincent il y en
aura d'autres mineurs incarcérés à qui
la justice proposera ce placement de 10
semaines
ce jour là la prison de brest quelques
minutes de parloir l'éducateur présente
à nouveau le contrat le jeune est libre
d'accepter ou de refuser m'a dit
clairement à première connerie devant le
juge dans ce coma comme un test quoi
pour voir si je risque encore de julien
si les gens avec ça se passe bien miche
de corps c'est quoi qui fait douter
surtout ce qui m'a dit quoi
quand li bruce à gages travail quoi tout
ça ce type mais puisque j'ai envie de
sortir mais en fait dans ma tête je
pense que je sais pas trop si j'arrive à
tous ces doutes parce que combien de
fois ils sont d'ailleurs il me disait
bien combien de fois et la première
jamais recommencé à faire des bêtises
tout ça pis bon ben ça fait peut-être
que là il va voir des adultes aussi en
face de nuit qui vont lui dire stop à
chaque fois parce qu'il faut rappeler
les interdits mais aussi parce qu'il
faut souvent materner la justice lui
donnera à lui aussi sa chance
à charge pour les éducateurs de faire de
l'encadrement renforcé un nouveau départ
à charge pour les jeunes de choisir à
bordeaux reprise du procès de maurice
papon l'accusé après deux semaines de
repos est apparue en bien meilleure
forme physique reportage dominique
verdeilhan dominique merlet étrange
raccourci de l'histoire maurice papon
arrive à 13 heures à la gare de bordeaux
le 28 août 42 444 juive dans 88 enfants
en étaient partis pour objet c'est le
deuxième convoi dont doit répondre
aujourd'hui l'accusé maurice papon
revigorés après deux jours de suspension
d'audience c'est très à l'aise mains
dans les poches qu'il répond aux
questions mari dsk le procureur général
maurice papon est très en verve il parle
de l'hypocrisie propre à la race
germanique admet qu'il a peut être
commis un crime de naïveté vis-à-vis des
allemands et puis maurice papon retourne
la situation
il interroge à son tour le procureur
général je voudrais bien comprendre ce
qu'on me reproche d'être intervenu ou de
ne pas être intervenu pour sauver des
juifs
le magistrat embarrassé répond ce qui
vous est reproché c'est de ne pas avoir
fait plus on est en train de constater
ont ce qu'on voit comme pour le
précédent
comme maurice pape en a fait arrêter
personne et le procès se déplace on lui
dit maintenant d'art depuis quelques
jours à vous ne l'avez pas sauver autant
nous comprenons difficilement pourquoi
le parquet général s'obstine à faire
dire monsieur papon qu'est ce qu'il
aurait pu faire de plus pour sauver des
gens puisque nous pensons nous
exactement contraire qu'il a tout fait
pour au contraire obéir aux ordres des
nazis à ce moment là ce n'est pas un jeu
moi je joue mon destin je joue ici ma
fin de vie assènera maurice papon
durant plus de quatre heures l'accusée a
ferraillé avec le procureur général
montant plusieurs fois au combat si les
allemands vous écouter aujourd'hui ils
vous fusille réelles en sera-t-il même
aux magistrats qui en est resté bouche
bée opération pièces jaunes les petites
pièces de monnaie collectée par
l'association dirigée par madame
bernadette chirac est parrainé par le
judoka david douillet l'année dernière
la collecte de 26
on de francs avait permis de financer
300 projets destinés à améliorer la vie
quotidienne des enfants hospitalisés
principalement permettre aux familles de
deux mairies auprès des petits malades
pendant la durée d'hospitalisation
reportage jean bernard schmid et
christian myon un couloir d'hôpital
transformer en pistes cyclables avec
passage piéton panneaux et sens
giratoire c'est l'une des réalisations
de l'opération pièces jaunes pour
améliorer la vie des enfants
hospitalisés en huit ans 1150 projet
concrétisé en tout 2200 tonnes de pièces
récoltées pour changer la vie des tout
petits pour moi dans un univers hôpital
où c'est que des plus fortes et porte
blanche et d il ya des jeux il ya des
couleurs et ça leur rappelle l'école ou
leur fille normale
les enfants avec les soit son film il
aime bien sortir de la chambre ou en
fait ils ont souffert un petit peu et
puis allez jouer les oubliées un petit
peu leur malheur aussi ici à l'hôpital
du kremlin bicêtre
on a aussi aménagé une maison des
enfants il s'y trouve des jeux les
ateliers des ordinateurs des activités
développées pour rendre moins difficile
un séjour à l'hôpital c'est très clair
aucun enfant si possible dans les
services de pédiatrie tous à l'école ou
à la maison des enfants et si possible
les parents en permanence avec leurs
enfants
par exemple les pièces jaunes ou
permettent nous ont permis de développer
des chambres mère enfant ou la mère peut
rester en permanence auprès de sont
éloignés de leurs parents de leurs amis
les enfants vivent toujours comme une
épreuve un séjour à l'hôpital pour que
leur vie ressemble plus possible à celle
de la maison les hôpitaux de france
compte sur les 2 millions 600 mille
tirelire installés partout en france
pour collecter les pièces rouges
onze ans après la mort du chanteur
daniel balavoine mort sur la piste du
paris dakar et qui s'était pris de
passion pour l'afrique son association
dirigée ou d'aujourd'hui par sa soeur
continue d'aider au quotidien les
africains n'ont pas une aide au niveau
national avec des risques de corruption
mais des pros
j'ai limité bien concrets au niveau du
terrain comme vous allez voir dans notre
enquête
il s'agit de l'arrivée d'une simple moto
pompes destinées à alimenter en eau
plusieurs villages du mali reportage
olivier les nous a à christian odin la
fondation daniel balavoine à gao visite
de claire l'une des soeurs du chanteur
disparu
dans cet atelier le mécanicien malien
formé en france prépare une motopompe
car on va faire la pts à céret pont le
moteur à son lieu de travail
c'est trop lourd une motopompe d'une
valeur de 50 mille francs
en tout il ya trente deux motopompes et
son qui sont répartis sur 25 villages 25
villages dont l'un mot sanga se trouve à
100 km de gao
mo en ga 2800 habitants un groupe ii à
m'opposer au bord du fleuve niger le
niger source de vie au mali qui est
engagée sur le fleuve donc il faut
transporter par kerax de ses moyens
qu'ils ont le périmètre de travail du
village 122 personnes s'activent sur une
surface de 20 hectares avec la motopompe
on n'a pas revu ni vraiment à mieux
rentabiliser ces terres là c'est à dire
c'est à dire que pendant la période
hivernale
la pluviométrie est très difficile car
ici c'est 200 300 mm par an et avec la
motopompe dont on propre le complément
nous permettre aux rides et bien germé
et avec la crise a conduit mozambique où
a été livré la première moto pompe
offerte par la fondation balavoine en
aujourd'hui cette moto pompe doit être
remplacé
puiser l'eau du fleuve à saint de la
redistribuer sur l'ensemble de la
plantation
grâce à un réseau de canaux d'irrigation
la motopompe qui permet d'alimenter les
parcelles situées au delà du fleuve
nous allons faire de campagne dans
l'allée et le perray campagne prévue
pour fin juin
ils ne savent à la campagne peut vous
faire descendre la mise en valeur des
terres un rendement annuel multiplié par
dix grâce à la motopompe les habitants
du village récolte tous les six mois
quatre tonnes de riz à l'hectare du riz
décortiqué par une machine offerte par
la fondation balavoine daniel balavoine
qui a toujours cru en son projet je
pense qu'il y avait une grande foi dans
les populations puisque c'est avec les
populations elles mêmes qu'ils avaient
établi ce type de travail et personne ne
pouvait douter déni des amis des autres
mais malheureusement elle n'a jamais pu
voir le résultat n'en est peut-être
qu'ils veillent au grain de temps en
temps un homme qui meurt de faim
aujourd'hui est une insulte à soi-même
et à l'humanité toute entière
quelques mots prononcés par daniel
balavoine
il y a déjà dix ans en algérie
l'enchaînement des massacres provoquent
des prises de positions en europe la
france appuie la demande allemande de
réunions dans un premier temps des hauts
fonctionnaires européens pour envisager
des mesures à prendre face à l'horreur
des événements en algérie au sein du
gouvernement
face au déferlement de violence il ya
ceux qui estiment qu'il faut armer la
population pour qu'elle puisse se défend
ce fut le cas après d'alger où grâce à
cet armement même sommaire un carnage a
pu être évité selon ce document fourni
par la télévision algérienne
les habitants de chebli aux portes
d'alger l'ont échappé belle dans la nuit
de jeudi à vendredi dernier quand ils
furent attaqués par un commando
comprenant deux ou trois hommes de leur
village
il nous appelait par nono mohamed ahmed
smaïn pour nous faire croire que c'était
des copains et nous attirer vers eux
dans l'obscurité et nous y sommes pas
allés chacun a continué sa garde
comme prévu le village avait déjà subi
un massacre les habitants s'étaient
armés
il y avait huit terroristes au pied de
ce mur
quelqu'un leur a tiré dessus
d'autres terroristes ont pris d'assaut
la maison du voisin l'un d'entre eux est
passée par là avec sa kalachnikov
mon voisin lui a tiré dessus et l'a
descendu c'est le voisin dans son
actuelle fils de 10 ans les autres
terroristes étaient restés sur place
je suis allé dans leur direction en me
voyant ils ont tiré une rafale
vous voyez c'est la juste au pied de ce
mur ugal encore les traces de balles
j'ai emmené ma mère ma petite soeur et
notre enfant je laissais fait passer par
la terrasse puis par seconde il ahmed a
vu les assaillants déroulé un câble de
mise à feu qui conduisait à cet explosif
un membre du groupe d'autodéfense a tiré
quatre balles dans leur direction à ce
moment là ils se sont enfuis et j'ai
entendu crier
venez venez vite ça suffit on repart
plusieurs des attaquants sont blessés
l'un d'entre eux sera retrouvé mort le
lendemain matin était en israël malgré
la démission de son ministre des
affaires étrangères david les villes
pommier benyamin nétanyahou a réussi à
faire adopter aujourd'hui son projet de
budget une victoire provisoire dit on
qui même promu ministre à la merci de
l'ultra droite nationaliste qui est
contre toute mesure de nouveau retrait
de forces israéliennes des territoires
palestiniens
l'affection des anglais pour la
princesse de galles ne se dément pas un
standard téléphonique permettant de
réserver pour l'été prochain un ticket
d'entrée dans le parc où elle est
enterrée a été véritablement pris
d'assaut aujourd'hui dès son ouverture
londres etienne leenhardt
voici donc le domaine des spencer en
passe désormais de se transformer deux
mois par an lieu de pèlerinage pour les
fidèles de la princesse de galles
enterrés là sur une petite île
l'hommage ne veut pas finir en témoigne
ce matin encore les bouquets et les
objets du culte accrochée aux grilles du
domaine familial et à l'ouverture des
réservations l'embouteillage attendu
était au rendez vous et la première
heure nous avons eu mille appels mais
nous demandons au public d'être patient
et de persévérer et de continuer à nous
appeler dans les jours prochains
grand maître des cérémonies le frère
cadet de diana le comte spencer qui
s'était et fleurissent et en solitaire
l'îlot où elle repose il a fixé le prix
du ticket d'entrée à 100 francs
un peu cher dira-t-on pour une simple
promenade dans le parc et la visite d'un
musée mais tous les profits iront à la
fondation bayane pour les 2500 visiteurs
qui chaque jour seront autorisés à
franchir les grilles du domaine le
privilège n'aura de toute façon pas de
prix l'afflux des visiteurs est assurée
je ne suis pas sûre qu'on y arrivera
notre village n'est pas fait pour
accueillir des grandes foules et toute
la circulation qui en découlent oui nous
sommes très inquiets
quatre mois après sa mort la princesse
de galles suscite toujours la même
ferveur 120 millions de timbres à son
effigie seront mises en vente le mois
prochain une autre façon d'entretenir le
cube pas de chance pour le broussy
américain steve fossett qui après
richard branson le pdg de virgin voulait
faire le tour du monde en ballon partie
de l'état du missouri de saint louis
mercredi dernier il a été contraint à un
atterrissage forcé dans le sud de la
russie
heureusement pour lui que la guerre
froide est terminée
titanic ce nom résonne comme celui de la
plus grande catastrophe maritime du 20e
siècle la plus tragique car le navire
avait été baptisé insubmersible et
l'océan et d'erreurs humaines
on a voulu autrement dans la nuit du 14
au 15 avril 1912 lors du voyage
inaugural le titanic earth est un
iceberg et sombrer dans l'océan glacé
faisant 13 116 victimes
c'est l'histoire du titre
ni que le cinéma américain nous présente
à partir de mercredi en france un budget
phénoménal 1 milliards 7
une reconstitution la plus fidèle
possible une production qui dure trois
heures vingt pascal deschamps pour la
première fois vous serez vraiment dans
le bain les canons du lot et de la cia
passé de canon pour tout le monde la
moitié des gens vont mourir
ce puits certes le titanic a déjà coulé
à l'écran mais c'est sans aucun doute la
reconstitution la plus fidèle la plus
réussie
la plus spectaculaire de cette tragédie
collective emblématique
dans ce nouveau scénario james cameron
mail le présent et le passé en partant
sur les traces d'une des survivantes 85
ans après une femme se souvient de son
amour pour un jeune aventurier du pont
inférieur
ensemble ils vivront cinq jours d'une
folle passion
ensemble ils vivront l'enfer du naufrage
tout a commencé le 30 mai 1996 sur la
côte de bassel informé ce jour là james
cameron donne le coup d'envoi du
tournage le plus cher de l'histoire
pour vous il a reconstruit le titanic
une copie conforme de 269 mètres de long
fidèle dans ses moindres détails
un véritable ou joie grandeur nature est
pour vous il l'a fait couler grâce aux
informations recueillies lors des
dernières plongent et la version qu'ils
donnent des faits est la bonne
pour moi c'est vraiment une histoire
exceptionnelle
monster mène fascinante et mon but était
de faire revivre l'émotion qui fut la
leur au cours de cette poignée d'heures
dans lesquelles le bateau s'est en fait
on peut comparer nouvelle car le premier
ciel est la première terre
il n'y avait plus de mer et
je suis
synthes
voici la demeure de dieu
non faire tout ça ça demande un travail
incroyable aimons très fort avec ce rôle
avec des choses que j'ai jamais vécue
auparavant pour les scènes
contemporaines james cameron affrété un
navire de drogue en équipage hautement
qualifiés ont plongé sur l'épave
ces images sont les leurs sans doute les
dernières tournées avant que les pins
s'enfonce dans les sables blancs qu'on
est tellement chez qui il a fallu qu'on
répète tout à la sicav on a construit
une petite maquette de l'épeuve et deux
petites maquettes dessous exactement les
trajets les gestes qu'on a refait
ensuite sous l'eau
titanic est un formidable spectacle dont
on sort sonné valait-il de dépenser plus
d'un milliard de francs quelle que soit
la réponse à cette question une chose
est sûre c'est sans doute la dernière
fois que l'on voit un tel film
titanesque dans ses ambitions même il
est le symbole d'une industrie du cinéma
pour l'été le rêve ne saurait avoir de
prix fiction réalité le titanic orgueil
de la flotte commerciale anglaise n'aura
donc jamais achevé son voyage inaugural
entre southampton et new york si la
catastrophe a fait 1300 16 morts il y
eut de même 700 six rescapés parmi
lesquels un français qui est toujours en
vie stéphane haumant rêver poissonnier
on l'avait surnommé le paquebot du
siècle il était le plus grand le plus
rapide le plus luxueux 269 mètres de
long une ville flottante réputé
insubmersible l'océan maîtrisé par la
technologie des hommes pour sa toute
première croisière le titanic kit
southampton en angleterre pour new york
900 membres d'équipage à bord et 1500
passagers
parmi eux michel daverat tive il avait 4
en 1912 il accompagnait son père parti
refaire sa vie en amérique et il se
souvient des trois premiers jours de
traversée idyllique
ce que je sais c'est que je jouais sur
le port j'ai souvenir aussi d'un repas
magnifique avec un salle à manger de
seconde classe
il y avait le vitre qui donnait sur la
mer 22 noeuds de moyenne le titanic est
parti pour battre un record mais à 23h40
le 14 avril par une belle nuit étoilée
il entre en collision avec un iceberg
c'est la panique
il n'y a pas assez de chaloupes pour
tous les passagers
l'eau de l'atlantique nord et glacé
l'évacuation se fait dans le plus grand
désordre
sauve qui peut dans les cabines
mon père est et entre m habiller
chaudement n'est ce pas là on a habillé
chaudement aussi bon mon frère on a été
jusqu'au bateau pourquoi votre père
n'est pas monté avec vous dans la
chaloupe habache que c'était pas parmi
les hommes ne devait pas amender ce jt
des bateaux l'eau des rameurs n'est ce
pas
les femmes et les enfants d'abord mais
surtout les premières classes
prioritaires les passagers sans fortune
eux sont bloqués par des grilles dans
les ponts inférieurs les 9/10 périront
noyer
on sait aujourd'hui que la collision a
provoqué six déchirure dans la coque du
titanic sous le poids de l'eau le navire
bascule vers l'avant et sa structure se
brise en deux chef-d'oeuvre de vanité
humaine
le titanic a sombré en seulement deux
heures 1316 mort la plus grande tragédie
de l'histoire maritime
est ce que le film vous allez allez le
voir après si je peux volontiers si je
peux je souhaite voir est ce que vous
n'avez pas peur que de revoir toute
cette histoire pendant trois heures
vingt ça soit vous re pour vous non
parce que la douleur j'allais déjà
ressortis n'est ce pas j'ai déjà
resserre dis-je jusqu'à + choix on a
retrouvé l'épave du titanic en 85 au
large du canada et il fascine encore les
hommes pour son histoire bien sûr mais
aussi pour d'autres rêves ses trésors
qui seraient englouties par 4000 mètres
de fond
à partir de mercredi donc sur les écrans
avant nous quitter le rappel des
principaux titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi 18 antennes des assedic sont
toujours occupées par des chômeurs
nouvelle occupation à paris et en région
parisienne
tempête sur la france des vents encore
proche de 100 km à aujourd'hui mais le
mauvais temps se déplace vers l'est
l'allemagne notamment les îles bretonnes
sont de nouveau relier au continent
depuis cet après midi dans un instant la
météo de sophie davant le vent soufflera
un peu moins fort donc demain mais
toujours ont beaucoup de pluie 20h50 la
troisième partie de la série entre terre
et mer demain 13h patrick chêne antoine
cormery quant à moi je vous retrouverai
demain soir à 20 heures je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée sur notre chaîne
besson